To make a reflection in the Y axis happen, we simply need to replace x in our
original function with negative x in the transformed function. So, here are the
four functions that Athena needs to make her final glasses frame logo. This is
pretty cool. With a couple of domain restrictions and a few other functions
added in, she could complete her picture like this. Or maybe she'd rather let
the functions themselves complete the glasses. Of course, adding in a couple of
other lines and points for wipers and nozzles. Either way, I think we've seen
just how powerful transformation of different kinds of functions can be. You've
learned about shifts, horizontally and vertically, reflections in the X-axis
and the Y-axis, and stretches and shrinks in the vertical direction. These are
all super powerful tools that can be used with any kind of function. Awesome
job. I'm sure Grant will be very pleased with this logo.